nuevos objetos sospechosos siguen
llegando a distintos puntos de la
geografía española el último que sería
ya El séptimo 9 días ha provocado hoy
que la policía acordonará de nuevo la
embajada de Ucrania en Madrid de un
cordón que ya se ha levantado al parecer
la delegación que el miércoles recibió
un sobre con material inflamable que
hirió levemente a un empleado habría
recibido un paquete esta vez con restos
de animales y sangre características que
comparte con paquetes recibidos por las
embajadas de Ucrania en Hungría Países
Bajos Polonia Croacia Italia o Austria
según el ministro de exteriores
ucraniano de microculeva forma parte de
una planificada campaña de terror e
intimidación aunque no está siendo
exitosa según ha afirmado el político
afirma que colaborarán con los países
extranjeros en la investigación Mientras
tanto la seguridad en los edificios
consulares y embajadas de Ucrania ha
sido reforzada por su parte el gobierno
de España ya afirma que los envíos de
seis sobres con material inflamable
podrían estar relacionados la invasión
de Ucrania y pide en una carta a sus
socios de la Unión Europea que se
evalúen las posibles acciones recordemos
que además de este último paquete con
restos de animales recibidos hoy entre
el 24 de noviembre y el 1 de diciembre
seis sobres llegaron a distintos
destinatarios incluidos el presidente
del gobierno o la ministra de defensa en
Madrid según la policía son de
fabricación casera y contenían pequeñas
cantidades de pólvora y metralla sin
embargo aún no hay información sobre
quién está detrás de los mismos